everyone's very excited about saving us
here but in certain parts of the
audience in the audience at home there
might be some disappointment because
people were perhaps hoping that they
would be seeing Matt Damon and his
ponytail it's quite the sensation this
summer ponytail man his ponytail when
did it go well I had it you know I did a
movie in China and in it and so I was
there for about five months with that
with that thing and then we did a press
conference at the very end no it was I
you know it was very it was hair
extensions oh it wasn't real no it took
there are seven hundred hair extensions
it was a full day to put them in they
flew somebody a wonderful woman from
here all the way to Beijing to do to do
it and we did it like on a Sunday it
took us the entire day so and then I had
to manage that here I never knew I have
a whole new appreciation for my wife and
daughter it's very hard to do because
Matt Damon's ponytail it ended up with
its own Twitter account
but also people you know people really
appreciated that ponytail on Twitter I
don't know if you found some of the
tweets that people - so mmm
Matt Damon with a man bun I said lady
boner
they they get worse you think you were
basically understanding of the world
then you see Matt Damon's ponytail and
nothing makes sense this one this one's
quite extreme
Matt Damon has a ponytail never would
sit at our table I think my ovaries
might explode so never put it in a top
who knows what this last one means Matt
Damon I will use your ponytail to steer
while you dine upon my lady sandwich
[Applause]
she's really thought it through
technically James Bourne has James
Bourne and Jason bond is fine I
literally looked at it I was alone with
it and I said to myself thank God I
didn't anybody over for this huh
and I suddenly had this kind of